will cause these criminal trial begins
this morning in Pennsylvania the 79 year
old actor/comedian is charged with three
counts of aggravated indecent assault
they stem from a 2004 incident with
former Temple University employee
employee andrea constand cosby claims
their interaction was consensual
Jericka Duncan is in Norristown that's
outside the Montgomery County Courthouse
with what we can expect
trick' good morning good morning people
are just starting to file into this
courthouse as the trial gets underway
shortly at the center of this trial is
andrea constand now she's maintained a
pretty low profile she along with
another one of Cosby's alleged accusers
are going to testify now bill cosby
himself is not expected to take the
stand if convicted of sexual assault he
faces up to 30 years in prison 12 jurors
will decide whether or not bill cosby is
guilty of alleged sexual assault of the
seven men and five women chosen 10 are
white and two are black Cosby is facing
assault accusations from more than 50
women but this trial will focus on the
claims of only one accuser andrea
constand
according to a criminal complaint cosby
invited constant over to his
philadelphia area home in the winter of
2004 to discuss her future career plans
he's accused of giving constant pills
wine and then sexually assaulting her
the document alleges constant
experienced inappropriate sexual
behavior at Cosby's house several times
before the alleged assault and she
waited nearly a year to report it
how'd you get good help in the 79 year
old actor and comedian has denied the
allegations Const and is set to testify
along with another Cosby accuser
there are basically three prongs to the
evidence that's expected to come out
against mr. Cosby at trial
Barry Colburn is a former federal
prosecutor and criminal defense attorney
one is the testimony of the complainant
and of course that's dependent on how
credible she is in the eyes of the jury
the next is the testimony of the
corroborated witness and the third is
mr. Cosby's deposition testimony during
a 2005 deposition Cosby admitted to
possessing quaaludes to use them on
young women he wanted to have sex with
Cosby later changed his answer and said
he misunderstood the question admitted
to possessing quaaludes but said he only
used them on one woman it's unclear if
Camille Cosby will be in court today
throughout these allegations she has
fiercely defended her husband of more
than 50 years Charlie Jericka thanks